sometimes you'll see a bear and feel and
think all right that was pretty awesome
but the most memorable barons deals
aren't always the cleanest or the most
kills when a bear and feel that should
never happen happens those are the ones
that are truly memorable so here are our
picks for the top 10 most insane barren
fields in League of Legends history
kicking off our list is expensive
Barents deal against immortals and while
it might have had little impact on the
outcome of the game you have to admire
how casually he just runs in steals the
baron and pieces out Ziya you're the
parent because that buys it for time
Louis maybe the time buyer of all time
buyers can he do it while he's there
it's a slight by big expanding he steals
it that counter logic gaming is very
much still in it maybe on the path to
victory with the follow up fight rate
over solo there's no hard flying in no
shot DP but he wasn't actually able to
get parent he's on to the Nexus doesn't
even matter the Xfinity just came up
that big yes it does what a barnburner
support seals are really rare so when it
happens on the world stage
it's absolutely mind-blowing number 9 is
Elvis's mantra inner fire seal from the
2016 World Championship surprise
themselves by the legendre feature on
the corner their jungler is still at the
base here so this is a little bit risky
certainly is tunnel comes back out there
no there is honor around the bear pit
they have the damage to get it done
[Applause]
can you do that possible most ridiculous
parents feel weird hopping in at number
eight its ml XG for his feel out from
under the nose of beachy gaming not only
did he beat out the legendary Ganges his
opponent was on nunu and he still got to
steal times when you can say this I
believe carries over heat its flames
when it might be doing more damage than
the equalizer next game right here just
because of how much I paid that lets
have to go here like this he stole the
berry neutralize it goes down Matta will
actually fall there's a Tristana now I
started moving it is also just the
cutest silly just blasted in fourth but
he's getting dumped there by the
Cataclysm does actually take al is
because that's a job and King might have
found a way back into this game
unbelievable steel coming out right
there you have to question dandy smiley
had ability to use consume and smite
right there persistence pays off in our
number seven planes as meteos didn't let
it roll or deftly there softens for
stealing baron from five members of Team
Liquid big old Baron buff maybe us is in
the area he's going to try for a steal
but I don't think you gonna get in time
about flash and smite in Phoenix wants
to assassinate you des very damaged not
quite enough maybe like if that is the
type of play that could kill you unreal
taking the number six spot is power of
evil shockwave steal from the 2015 u LCS
summer playoff not only was the steal a
fantastic display of timing it was a
dagger through the hearts of SK gaming
who were heavy favorites in the series
of unicorns of last notch he could jump
into this area let's see what Freddy can
do remember there's no deep mark
available if a good shock wave hit I
think that might be the only way Freddy
dragons the sentencer / Baron will be
secured
and stolen power of evil has kept dirty
cold in the semi-final energy steal from
the 2015 MSI wild-card qualifier comes
in at number five with a spot at MSI on
the line
this game was crucial to make matters
even more intense he beat out not one
but two smites to get the feel how does
that even happen so she's gonna have to
go in he's looking for something jokes
up very very low talk is looking for
something as well as all of his men
about misses the top energy steals up
Baron somehow I have absolutely no idea
that they ultimately come through over
the side Dumbledore's looking for
stalkers here as he locks him down Macao
is going to get the killer to double
dose double kill coming through for
voltar actually is how did that happen
we all know cyanide is the prince of
beef with plenty of insane feel
throughout his career but taking number
four on our list is one of his first and
most famous feeling the Baron from
against all authority at the season One
World Championship look at the vision
right now fnatic knows triple-a knows
Davis bought it now but can they get it
in time it's going to be close and
I'm not quite sure it is yet the soul is
started and it grabbed by fanatic is a
good trait for them they feel it's going
to turn out looks like Kuja already said
yells are getting crushed right now by
shushei and the rest and this was
looking so good romantic right now
ultimately trying to run away great
double knock up and they always going to
block out two of themselves going down
MoMA and leenock both very low and Senna
getting C it easy to walk back yellow
saw and Lee and I are the only ones left
alive we've already seen one support
steel baron and coming in at number
three is another blood waters infamous
barons filled with a rank one Janna
tornado possibly the lowest damage
ability to ever steal a baron few feels
will ever be as insane as this one this
is the like extra breaking point for
Vulcan right now
if they give up this Baron then I think
they will have a lot of struggle going
through this game expert he's going to
try miracle steel and cloud nine is
going to try to not let that happen I
was I have to do is stand within that
queue if he gets it and get that percent
damage into the smite and it's quite
hard to dodge but look at that hall just
break a humid wall here anybody coming
in they could get the pole on they do oh
no they do not a guy there is a bird the
shield's going to wear off your time all
the ultimate goes across he gets out
with 100 HP supply oh my god
Wow blood water skills buried with I
don't even know it with a rake one
tornado coming in at number two is
piglets blind Baron steel against TSM
next to no mana no vision no problem for
piglet who snatches the Baron with a
single rocket in front of five members
of TSM Lima Oscar Lila Eric yes it is
rib yeah
it is TSM waiting for the 1p pipe once
again and deep liquid handed to them on
a silver platter they start up the Baron
just because Turtles bottom you are not
late game yet this is only 26 minutes
then you can't burn through this barrage
an ad carry big bucks all lit up with a
big one scale
[Applause]
and taking our top spot it's messed
barons field from Game five of the 2016
lck summer finals not only did his
gangplank Ultimates secure the Baron
with two HP less rocks would go on to
finally win their first lck title off of
this play while our hearts ache for
score this is not only one of the most
important baron skills ever but also the
most insane can they take it out though
it's still risky he put me down my own
is off remember Rox Tigers fighting for
their tournament life here fighting
professor seems like Baron take it taken
my soul offensive Eric they're going
after play now
bedrock players turning it around Johnny
solo lievable marriage steel he did Jose
were our picks for the top 10 most
insane barons deals of all time can you
think of another Baron feel that should
be on the list or is there another top
10 that you'd like to see let us know in
the comment section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button